YOU CANNOT MAKE THIS STUFF UP.
IT DOVE TAILS TO BREAKING NEWS
OPENING MONOLOG.
SO THE SICK, TWISTED, MEPTD
ALLEY UNSTABLE ANTI-TRUMP
MEDIA AGAIN WORKING ITSELF
INTO A NEW MANUFACTUREDINTO A ND
FRENZY.
NOW, WE HAVE BEEN COMPLAINING
HOW THE BIAS PRESS OPERATES IN
THIS COUNTRY FOR A WHILE.
HERE’S HOW IT WORKS.
RUSH FROM ONE FABRICATED
MELTDOWN TO ANOTHER AND IN THE
PROCESS THESE BRAIN-DEADPROCESSD
SO-CALLED JOURNALIST BOUNCE
AROUND AND SAME TALKING POINT
AND LITTLE FAKE NEWS BUBBLE
ECHO CHAMBER.
AND IT BECOMES A COMPETITION
TO SEE WELL, WHO CAN SAY THE
MOST OUT LANDISH AND THE MOST
OFFENSIVE AND THE MOST FALSE
THING ABOUT PRESIDENT TRUPP.
IT’S LIKE THEY’RE HIP KNOW
ADVERTISED LOBOTAMIZED ROBOTS
AND IT’S SAD AND PREDICTABLE
AND THEY’RE NOT SERVING YOU
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
THEY’RE SHEEP, CLOSE MINDED
AND CONVINCED THEMSELVES THIS
IS PSYCHOTIC PART THROUGH
THEIR OWN CONSPIRACY THEORIES
THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP SURPRISE
SUFFERING FROM DEMENTIA AND
HAS EARLY ONSET ALZHEIMER’S
AND DE RANGED.
NOW THE NEWEST FAKE NEWS
FIXATIONS IS ALL ABOUT THE
PRESIDENT’S HEALTH.
THINK HE WOULD BE HAPPY
NATURALLY AFTER THE
PRESIDENT’S DOCTOR TOLD THEM
HE WAS IN EXCELLENT, I REPEAT,
EXCELLENT PHYSICAL CONDITION.
AND THIS SHOCKED THEM.
COULD EASILY SERVE FOR TWO
THE MEDIA COULD NOT BELIEVETHE E
IT.
IT GOES AGAINST EVERYTHING
THEY’VE ALL BEEN TELLING
THEMSELVES.
HOUR AFTER HOUR, DAY AFTERHOUR R
DAY.
WEEK AFTER WEEK.
MONTH AFTER MONTH.
THE PRESS CANNOT STAND THE
FACT THAT THE PRESIDENT SCORED
A PERFECT 30/30 ON COGNITIVE
SCAM.
AND MY GUESS MOST OF THE
PEOPLE IN THE MEDIA WORLD
WOULD ROBABLY FAIL THE TEST IF
THEY TOOK IT THEMSELF.
I WOULD LOVE TO TEST THEM.
BEFORE WE SHOW YOU NEW
EXAMPLES IT’S IMPORTANT TO
HIGHLIGHT HOW UTTERLY INSANE
THE MEDIA WAS WITH THE
PRESIDENT’S DOCTOR.
WATCH THIS.
>> DO YOU KEEP A TALLY OF HOW
MUCH GOLF THE PRESIDENT PLAYS.
>> SO. PRESIDENT’S PRENDZ
TOLD REPORTERS THEY HI HE’S A
GERM OWE PHONE AND WASHES HIS
HANDS OBSESSIVELY YOU DO YOU
SEE ANY INDICATION OF THAT
TYPE OF BEHAVIOR?
>> SEDENTARYY LIFESTYLES ARE A
PERSPECTIVE YOU CAN GO BACK ON
SGLAT ANY EVIDENCE OF BONE
SPURS THAT HE SAID HE UVR ISED
FROM?
>> IS HE LIMITED TO --
>> YEAH TWITTER DOESN’T
INVOLVE ME AS A DOCTOR.
I HAVE NO CONCERN ON THAT.
>> DOES THE PRESIDENT WEAR DEN
TURZ.
>> THE PRESIDENT HAS NO
PARTIAL DENTURES OF ANY KIND.
>> YOU SAID HE DOESN’T DRINK
OR SMOKE OTHER THAN DIET ISSUE
DID YOU ADDRESS DRUG
ADDICTION.
>> DRUG ADDICTION.
>> YEAH.
>> ANY OTHER DRUGS.
>> NO HE HAS NO DRUG>> NO HE HAG
ADDICTION.
>> THIS IS REAL REPORTING.
THIS QUESTIONING WENT ON FOR
49 STRAIGHT MINUTES.
AND THE MEDIA REFUSED TO FACE
THE TRUTH, THE REALITY.
PERFECTLY HEALTHY.
YOU THINK THEY WOULD BEYOU THINE
HEALTHY.
APPARENTLY NOT.
IT DIDN’T TAKE LONG FOR TRUMP
HELD TRUTHERS.
THINK ABOUT THIS THEY COME OUT
IN THE MEDIA AND NOW THEY’RE
QUESTIONING EVERYTHING THAT
THE DOCTOR SAID.
THIS IS UNBELIEVABLE.
WATCH THIS.
>> THE ALLEGED EXCELLENT
MEDICAL SCAM RESULTS OF THE
FELLOW IN THE WHITE HOUSE WAS
SPAWNED -- HAS SPAWNED A NEW
CONSPIRACY IS THEORY KNOWN AS
GIRTHER MOVEMENT.
>> HE’S IN EXCELLENT HEALTH.
SANYEHA CAME OUT WITH NOT SO
THE SURE ABOUT EXCELLENT HEL
SGLJ WHEN HE SAID 239 POUNDS
WHATEVER.
>> I’M NOT BEING A GIRTHER.
>> THAT’S 6’ 3", 239 POUNDS
LOOKS LIKE THAT’S A SHOCK TO
ME.
>> I’M NOT SURE IF IT MAKES ME
FEEL BETTER THAT THIS DOCTOR
SAYS HE HAS NO COGNITIVE
ISSUES.
IT MAKES ME FEEL WORSE.
AND MORE WORRIED FOR THE
COUNTRY.
>> WHITE HOUSE PRESS CORPS
SEEMED STUNNED THAT THE
PRESIDENT, WHO CANNOT BUTTON
THE BUTTON ON HIS SUIT COAT,
IS NOT MUCH HEAVIER.
>> MONTREAL COGNITIVE
ASSESSMENT IS A FAIRLY LOW
LEVEL TEST AND UNBELIEVABLY
GOOD AT PREDICTING DEMENTIA OR
PREDEMENTIA.
IT DOESN’T SAY HE’S NOT
MORALLY OR MENTALLY UNFIT TO
BE PRESIDENT.
IT JUST SAYS HE DOESN’T HAVE
PREDEMENTIA.
>> WE’LL LISTEN TO DR. LIBERAL
JOE AND DR. MICCA AND CNN TOOK
THINGS FURTHER WITH MORBID AND
SAD PREDICTION.
THIS IS NUTS ABOUT PRESIDENT
TRUMP.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THIS CORE OWE FAIRY CALCIUM
SCORE IS ONE CARDIOLOGISTS USE
TO BE PREDICTIVE ANDTO BE PREDID
PROACTIVE.
AND IF THE THE NUMBER GETS UP
OVER 100 IS THAT THE
CONCERNING TO A LOT OF
DOCTORS.
CONCERNING BECAUSE YOU CAN
START TO SAY WELL, IF YOU DO
NOTHING DIFFERENT AND IF
THINGS DON’T CHANGE YOU CAN
START TO PREDICT LIKELIHOOD OF
HAVING SOME SORT HEART EVENT,
CARDIAC EVENT HEART ATTACK OR
SOMETHING LIKE THAT WITHIN A
CERTAIN NUMBER OF YEARS.
SO THE PRESIDENT HAS HEART
DISEASE.
THOSE NUMBERS QUALIFY HIM FOR
HAVING HEART DISEASE AND
CLEARLY NEEDS A PLAN TO
PREVENT SOME SORT OF HEART
PROBLEM DOWN THE ROAD.
>> REALLY?
HE’S NEVER EXAMINED THE
PRESIDENT.
WE KNOW THAT FAKE NEWS CNN I
HAVE A NEW NAME IN A SECOND WE
KNOW THEY HATE THE PRESIDENT.
REALLY?
THEY’LL PREDICT A GUY THAT
NEVER EXAMINED THE PRESIDENT
THAT HE’S GOING TO HAVE A
HEART ATTACK?
THIS TYPE OF BEHAVIOR
SHOULDN’T BE SURPRISESHOULDN’T .
ESPECIALLY COMING FROM WHAT
WE’RE NOW CALLING YOU SEE IT
RIGHT THERE, CNN THE SH-HOLE
NETWORK OR FAKE NEWS NETWORK
CNN MANAGED TO SAY THAT WORD
HUNDREDS OF TIME IN ONE WEEK
ALONE.
HERE ARE SOME OF THE EXAMPLES
I PROMISE I PLAYED THEM ALL.
HERE’S SOME WE’LL PUT ON THE
WEB SITE TOMORROW.
>> WHAT WAS YOUR REACTION WHEN
YOU HEARD THE PRESIDENT CALL
AFRICAN NATIONS [BLEEP] HOLES.
>> IT’S NOT CLEAR WHAT HE
MEANT BY [BLEEP] HOLE COUNTRY.
>> ARE YOU SHOCKED OR
SURPRISED BY THIS.
>> I’M NOT SURPRISED.
IN ONE WAY I’M PROUD I’M A
PROUD [BLEEP] HOLEPROUD [BLEEP].
>> NO WE ARE NOT ALL CREATED
EQUAL NOT IF YOU ARE BORN IN
AS THE PRESIDENT PUT IT HOLE
COUNTRY.
>> THE WORD HOUSE INSTEAD OF
HOLE AS IN HOUSE CURRENTYES
NOT HOLE COUNTRIES.
>> I GUESS HE’S A HOLE>> I GUESD
IS THERE A DIFFERENCE IF THE
PRESIDENT SAID [BLEEP]PRESIDENT]
[BLEEP].
>> DO YOU THINK THESE
COUNTRIES ARE [BLEEP].
>> AND DONALD TRUMP TURNED
OVAL OFFICE IN A [BLEEP].
>> HOLE>> HOLIERS BUILT THIS COY
110 YEARS AGO.
>> DID YOU SEE THE PRESIDENT
HOLE COMMENTS.
>> [BLEEP] [BLEEP] [BLEEP]
[BLEEP] [BLEEP] [BLEEP] HOLE
[BLEEP] HOLE [BLEEP] HOLE
COUNTRY.
>> DO YOU HAVE AN EXAMPLE OF
ANY [BLEEP] HOLE COMPANIES.
>> HOLE, HOLE.
>> I WORK FOR [BLEEP] [BLEEP]
[BLEEP] HOLE HOLE, I’M PROUD.
I’M PROUD TO BE A HOLIER
[BLEEP] [BLEEP] I WOULD SAY
HOLE ON TELEVISION AND [BLEEP]
[BLEEP].
>> CONGRATULATIONS CNN YOU DID
MORE THAN ENOUGH TO EARN YOUR
NEW NICKNAME THE [BLEEP] HOLE
NETWORK FAKE NEWS NETWORK KEEP
UP THE GOOD WORK.
YOU WOULD THINK CNN AFTER
HEARING THIS OVER AND OVER
AGAIN FOR THE PERSON PEOPLE
WHAT I AM ABOUT TO PLAY MAYBE
THEY WOULD LISTEN AND SAY I’M
NOT DOING SOMETHING RIGHT
HERE.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> ARE THEY NOT LISTENING?
APPARENTLY THEY ARE SOAPPARENTLO
HARD-HEADED, THAT NOTHING
SINKS IN.
ALSO, TONIGHT, WE HAVE MAJOR
BREAKING NEWS THIS IS
IMPORTANT TONIGHT ABOUT THE
PHONY FAKE NEWS, HILLARY
CLINTON BOUGHT AND PAID FOR
RUSSIAN AND PAID FOR DOSSIER
THAT LONG TIME CLINTON AID
ADVISOR BLOOMENTHAL WAS
INTERVIEWED IN 2015 BY FAKE
NEWS DOSSIER AND CONGRESSIONAL
INVESTIGATORS ARE WORKING TO
DETERMINE WHETHER OR NOT THE
OBAMA STATE DEPARTMENT WAS
INVOLVED IN GATHERING AND
CIRCULATING FICTITIOUS AND
TOTALLY FAKE INFORMATION FOUND
THAT DOSSIER GETTING DEEPER
EVERY NIGHT AND ACCORDING TO
ANOTHER REPORT A FBI AGENT
EXCHANGED INFORMATION ABOUT
THE BUREAU RUSSIA
INVESTIGATION WITH THE FORMER
SPY THAT WAS GETTING THE THE
PHONEPHONY RUSSIAN INFORMATION.
CHRISTOPHER STEEL.
HE IS THE GUY THAT PUT THE
DOSSIER TOGETHER.
YOU HAVE STEEL BEING TOLD BY
OUR FBI ABOUT THEIR RUSSIA
INVESTIGATION AT THE SAME TIME
STEEL IS GETTING PAID BY
HILLARY CLINTON TO DIG UP
PHONY RUSSIAN PROPAGANDA
SOURCE DIRT ON DONALD TRUMP.
YOU CANNOT MAKE IT UP AND WE
ALSO KNOW FROM FUSHIAN GPS
FOUNDER THAT STEEL BRIEFED FBI